and I'm sure there's some studies out
there that that can show that you not
hugging another person is like bad for
your mental health you know like for
sure like you need something that's like
a pervert to defense
my mental health man it's deteriorating
serotonin and dopamine I have to hug you
I gotta spoon somebody or I'll fail
[Music]
and
a high school
in the UK that's why you're here nice
okay you are the voice of the UK right
now I'm ready for it has banned all
physical contact and romantic
relationships between students and is
now
getting some frustrated parents making
some comments what is everybody's
opinion and take on a high school
Banning physical contact and romantic
relationship I'll be like hey you trying
to [__] block my kids
once they're all daughters you're trying
to talk about all my daughters come on
is that what you is that what you mean
by the parents are frustrated they're
frustrated in that way because I thought
parents would like that no no there's
there's uh some parents are getting mad
because it's like that's too Draconian
oh some parents are in support because
they're like that's proper in terms of
getting people ready for uh an
employer's workspace yeah but then some
people are like that's that's taking
away a lot of the regular experience
like for example physical contact and
romantic relationships covers the entire
element So Physical you would get in
trouble for fighting obviously yeah
because that's the contact but then
you'd also get in trouble for like
hugging your friends it's like you can't
do it so all touching yeah physical
contact I don't know that kind of
diminishes your ability to have any like
social Dynamic intelligence
especially at that age right which is
kind of what we've also because you
don't even know how to navigate it right
yeah like maybe they're just trying to
be old school British where they're like
bowels and curtsies won't that make kids
hornier a little bit oh dude yeah yeah
they'll probably push back a little bit
because you gotta even shake hands you
can't even [__] like dab people up
you can't you just gotta be like
hello
I'm sure I'm I'm sure that obviously
like little things like that you know
eventually get away with it but for sure
romantic relationships PDA obviously
fighting but we already get that you
know but like I think it's more the yeah
with Colleen's point the idea of like
you know social learning and stuff like
that um it's kind of a that's the time
right plus I don't think just because
the rules in place is going to stop
people from doing it
especially if you have the vast majority
of the people doing it what are you
going to do is expel everybody yeah how
they enforce that anyway right right
they should expel everybody and you're
left with five students and they're all
weirdos
freaks
sometimes it makes me think like what's
the point you know I get like you always
try to like progress so you try to
change things what's the end goal yeah
but there's a point where it's like oh
this thing's running pretty cool like
let's put into cruise control but they
don't want to though no they've got to
keep changing everything and they keep
the executive head teacher Maggie
calligan has defended the policy and
said the school is focused on
encouraging pupils to behave
professionally it's like they can't hug
yeah but that's like what profession you
can get into a lot of professions where
that type of thing oh my God they act
like school gets you ready for the
school the workplace good luck come on
[__] out of here she she said that most
parents and people support the policy as
it encourages peoples to behave
professionally as any future employer
would expect whereas one fresher parent
who wished to remain nameless spoke to
local media and expressed her annoyance
at the new policy coming into effect uh
she said I couldn't believe it in this
day and age I agree that inappropriate
touch hitting and punching of course has
to be dealt with but they're not
teaching students how to have a healthy
relationship the inference is that you
can't touch anyone children won't know
what it is or isn't appropriate what is
or isn't appropriate and the ability to
empathize with their peers is being
taken away yeah it's an extreme it's
like when you put in extreme situations
I mean there's the argument that people
want aren't going to follow it and
people who are going to do it anyways
are going to just do it and then the
fact that it's that extreme is just
going to push people to to just that's
attractive to do yeah sure and I don't
know or I don't know any workplace where
like well every single one that I've
been to if someone has something to
celebrate like I remember
um she this girl got engaged and then
all of her co-workers were like
congratulations they all hugged all that
stuff and I'm like that's normal culture
that's normal [__] to do like
so I'm like are they gonna refrain from
that or are there a lot of workplaces
that don't congratulate and hug and do
normal [__] like that because I've never
worked in a space that well isn't our
first language body language and being
able to communicate in that way yeah
[Music]
it came straight out the womb dude
yeah this uh this lady said I have a
daughter and her and her friends greet
each other with a hug but if they do
that now they'll face being put into
isolation that's so stupid you know what
sex too is I feel like that's more of
like a girl to guy thing that happened
in school yeah I feel like uh girls were
more like Huggy than guys were anyway
yeah we hug each other when we leave at
this workplace don't we yeah but like we
grew up and also while we came out of
the closet because you guys remember
being in school and if like a girl
socked you that was her flirting with
you in a way you know like when you
punch her back right how you supposed to
know we're idiots guys are idiots and
I'm sure there's some studies out there
that that could show that you not
hugging another person is like bad for
your mental health you know like for
sure like you need something that's like
a pervert to defense my mental health
man it's deteriorating serotonin and
dopamine I have to hug you I gotta spoon
somebody or I'll fail
don't debunk me in front of everybody
dude
comparatively just based off of what
you've been able to observe between like
the UK versus like the US for example
um what is what is like the uh stigma on
like PDA you're well more emotional here
here oh yeah really oh yeah it's much
more like stiff up a lip in the UK we
don't show affection because they always
smell this [__] on the ground wait what
do you mean how does that correlate
because they always look like this oh
dear
emotional about it oh I see what you
mean like it's a habit it's just it's
just yeah it's like shaking a hand or
something whereas like I walk in here
everyone's like hey and then in Britain
it'll be like you're all right
way down here America's up here oh they
play it up too here yeah whereas here
it's like Britain it's down there so
maybe she was just like look guys you're
acting too America oh we need to Reign
this back that's the motivation yeah
she's like this is not what we are tone
it down stiff up a lip what would
Churchill say stop hugging
actually makes a lot of sense now so
because this is in the UK it's not
necessarily that giant of like a concept
to you whereas for here I think here
people will be like in a [__] uproar
oh dude yeah it's an American brother I
feel like something triggered it
like maybe hella kids were just late for
class and there was just an orgy in like
the science room
maybe in your school Anthony Lee because
I feel like it was fun when I was in
school like we would get told off a
little bit for hugging and fighting for
fighting yeah well they banned like some
it depends what you're doing because we
used to play rugby and like British
Bulldog and things like that so that's
kind of the same thing
what is that that's bands band now
so you've got a playground concrete
ground right you've got a wall here
you've got 30 kids here one kid in the
middle those 30 kids have to get to the
other side and this kid in the middle
has to stop them by just like piling and
then if you get taken down you're now in
the middle so it ends with like 20 kids
in the middle 10 kids trying to run
across and we just body slam them to the
ground yeah that's tight and they don't
allow kids to play that anymore cool
people got damaged we used to go because
if it's concrete yeah well they banned
it first you weren't allowed to play on
concrete ground yeah that was when I was
in school like towards the end and then
they just band all together
[Laughter]
yeah it doesn't it was definitely not as
hardcore as that yeah that's cool that
sounds great that sounds really cool we
used to play this game called kill the
carrier where one kid will have a
football or something and they have to
make it from one end of the field to the
other and then everyone has to pile on
isn't that rugby but like with less
rules I guess but it's like one person
against everyone so like everyone has to
take like everyone has to tackle into
the ground and whoever tackles them to
the ground becomes the carrier and then
they gotta run it back the opposite way
we had fight to get out of the room what
that's really fun you're just in a room
and the last one after tour loses oh
[__] usually the first one of the door
gets messed up the most because that guy
grabs a knob everyone grabs that guy so
everyone's just fighting to get out and
if you're the last one out then you lose
that's great training for crisis
management it's awesome yeah screw
everybody else save yourself yeah that's
the American way anytime it's like a
mass shooting that starts happening
you're like I'm not going for the door
first I know how this [__] works out
yeah yeah you let everybody fight it and
then you just roll over everybody yeah
oh yeah I imagine you do get messed up
it was just basic basic rugby
I see one slight Pro in the idea of like
Prohibition in different ways like
imagine you put these kind of like no
touching blah blah
um and people get used to it and you
accept it that means like the moment
like a girl makes like eye contact with
you suddenly that's like that's like
holding your hand or if like yeah or if
like somebody's just like Taps you like
your hand or something like that that's
like as you'll get a boner you know what
I'm saying like back to seeing women's
ankles yeah you're just like sexting
with notes passing notes I mean they're
doing everything digitally now no
they're drawing you're drawing the
phones now
they've taken away
stupid
because because it's that's like what it
was in like elementary school right like
in elementary school you're not really
allowed to do certain obviously you know
you don't know what's going on
but you're so young and you're so you're
so green to those Concepts that when
they're introduced to you you're like is
a big [__] deal you like tell all
your friends and stuff like that but I
can only imagine what that is at a high
school level right when you're
technically supposed to be like more
mature in that understanding if you will
I remember one of the first things was
uh if a girl sat on your lap and then
you got a boner and they didn't leave
that was like the first step to like
sexual kind of oh [__] I got some action
yeah and they didn't leave yeah they
just stayed there the whole time
for how long first of all I'm like I'd
even invite you that's the test I'd even
invite you to sit on my lap but you're
here yeah and I can't control my penis
right now and I'm trying to wiggle away
but they're staying there I'm just gonna
stay in this position and then your legs
fall asleep
the first time a girl like straddles sat
on my lap was in lab straddles yeah like
this because I was like dating her kind
of we were like I was like a sophomore
and then all my friends went ew and then
I went yeah ew
why you peer pressure man yeah peer
pressure yeah
are people here or in the UK more or
less likely to be kind of prude like the
comfort with their sexuality and stuff
like that I think where
less like there's more sense of shift
yet on TV and things like that but I
think behind closed doors were kinkier
but up front we don't talk about it as
much in the UK yeah like we joke about
it like it's a funny thing but not like
so chatty but behind closed doors I
think we're Kink here than Americans
yeah
I would say so we're all talk huh yeah
and then I think that's accurately
where's like Joe's level with that
though you know what I mean in terms of
King Joe is all [__] yeah yeah he is a
handsome one too he told us about you
and sex so much I am a warrior
redraw his own penis imagination it's
like this is what my dick looks like
[Music]
okay